Because Lobsterfest
ends April 22nd.
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
IT'S TIME FOR OUR INAUGURAL
"DEFENDING OUR FIRST" SEGMENT
WHERE WE EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
CHECK THIS OUT.
LAST MONTH, ROCKLAND HIGH SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA PLACED HISTORY
TEACHER JULIAN BENDEL ON PAID
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE AFTER SHE
HAD THE GALL TO QUESTION
WHETHER THE SCHOOL WOULD LET
ITS STUDENTS WALK OUT.
TO PROTEST ABORTION.
THE SAME WAY IT DID TO PROMOTE
GUN CONTROL.
NOW ONE OF HER STUDENTS IS
PUTTING HER QUESTION TO THE TEST
BY ORGANIZING A PRO-LIFE WALKOUT
SET FOR 10:00 A.M. LOCAL TIME
TOMORROW.
JOINING US NOW FOR MORE, IS
JULIANN BENZEL HERSELF.
THIS IS GOOD BECAUSE THIS IS
LIKE, YOU ARE A HERO OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IN MY VIEW
BECAUSE THE STUDENTS IN ALL OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS WHO ORGANIZE
AND THEY DID REALLY WELL, THE
MARCH FOR OUR LIVES.
THE VARIOUS WALKOUTS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE LAST MONTH OR
SO, THEY GOT HUGE PARTICIPATION.
THEY GOT HUGE MEDIA COVERAGE.
MOST OF IT WAS OVERWHELMINGLY
POSITIVE.
GLOWING.
WHAT HAVE YOU FOUND WITH YOUR
EFFORT AT YOUR SCHOOL?
>> WELL, BASICALLY, THE ONLY
LARGE ENTITY THAT I KNOW OF THAT
HAS TAKEN UP THIS PRO-LIFE
WALKOUT BECAUSE IS TONY PERKINS
OF THE FAMILY RESEARCH COUNCIL.
I WAS THINKING, AND TO YOUR
POINT THERE, PERHAPS THERE WOULD
BE OTHER, MAYBE A CLINT EASTWOOD
OR A BRAVE MOVIE STAR FROM
HOLLYWOOD BECAUSE THEY HAD
GEORGE CLOONEY FUNDING THE GUN
PROTEST WALK ON.
I WAS HOPING MAYBE FOR A FEW
OTHER PEOPLE TO JOIN.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S ALL ABOUT GRASSROOTS AND
WHAT WE ARE FEELING, THE PULSE
OF THE NATION RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
IS EXTREMELY EXCITING.
>> Laura: I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SAVING LIVES, WHICH WE ALL
WANT TO DO.
WE ALL WANT TO HAVE SENSIBLE
REGULATIONS THAT DON'T RUN AFOUL
OF THE CONSTITUTION.
IN THIS CASE, THE DOMINANT
CULTURE DOES NOT PROMOTE THE
CAUSE OF LIFE.
IN FACT, THEY CALL THE CAUSE OF
LIFE ANTIABORTION RIGHTS
ADVOCATES.
THEY DON'T REFER TO A PRO-LIFE
ON CBS OR MSNBC.
I KNOW BECAUSE I USED TO WORK AT
BOTH PLACES.
THEY SAY YOU ARE ANTI-SOMETHING.
I AM FINDING STUDENTS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES, AND YOU SEE THIS
AT THE MARCH FOR LIFE EVERY
YEAR, THEY ARE MUCH MORE OPEN TO
THE IDEA OF THIS REALLY IS A
HUMAN BEING.
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS TO A NEW
GENERATION OF AMERICANS?
WE ARE SNUFFING THEM OUT A
MILLION OTHER TIME.
EVERY YEAR, ANOTHER MILLION.
BY CHEMICAL OR SURGICAL
ABORTIONS.
YET THE MEDIA, THEY ACT LIKE
THIS DOESN'T EVEN, THIS PRO-LIFE
VIEWPOINT DOESN'T EVEN EXIST.
>> CORRECT.
THAT'S WHY MY VERY BRAVE STUDENT
CHOSE TO STAGE IT AS A PRO-LIFE
WALKOUT.
NOT ANTIABORTION.
WE ARE FOR ALL LIFE, ALL
STUDENTS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES BYGONES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
BUT THIS IS A PRO-LIFE, EVERY
LIFE MATTERS.
YOU ARE PRECISELY RIGHT.
I FORGOT HER NAME RIGHT NOW.
THE OUTGOING PRESIDENT OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHO SAID HER
GOAL WAS TO --
ES, HER BOOK.
HER GOAL WAS TO DESTIGMATIZE
ABORTION IN THE UNITED STATES
AND I'M SORRY.
BUT THAT HAS NOT TAKEN PLACE.
TWO ARTICLES THAT I READ GAVE
VERY SPECIFIC STATISTICS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS AND
THE MAJORITY OF WOMEN ARE
PRO-LIFE, NOT FOR ABORTION.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING WHAT